you know it's still going strong though
walmart walmart and
walmart will always go strong right it's
got everything there
telling you all right live look outside
great shot from our tower cam we
had a great sunset now going down a
little bit but again go to our social
media where i put it all out there for
you to go see
all the sunsets we had from our tower
cams we got nine of them and we have a
tenth one on the way
57 degrees our high for the day today
that is our normal
39 our normal that's what we hit so look
at that we matched our temperatures
record territory 75. that's that way
back in 1962. now on to our
neighborhoods 55 for centennial hills
someone you're still at 54 55 also
aleante sky canyon that includes all of
you up there watching us at this hour
downtown north las vegas we got a lot of
viewers there too 55 degrees
58 sunrise mountain 58 also green valley
henderson 55 rhodes ranch
at 56 degrees bye kirsten we'll see you
tomorrow
four o'clock 54 degrees for pro boulder
city 54 63 for laughlin there's the
clouds like we pinpointed out to you
doppler network again
trying to find some precip showers
nothing nothing in southern california
either we could certainly use it
just not seeing it from these batches of
clouds and move through more clouds in
the forecast for tomorrow from this
system now
here's the deal with this one it's going
to track to the north
steer clear of us unfortunately not
going to bring us any rainfall and then
head
east of us here in the four corners
region bringing some snow in the rockies
which we'll take you
need it for the western portions of the
rockies but also increase our winds for
the weekend
tomorrow those winds should stay rather
tame rather light but then we get to
your weekend there's friday there's
saturday you'll see these numbers really
start to light up okay
because we do expect a breezy day for
saturday where your gusts could get up
25
locally higher 30 to 35 for the lake and
then sunday some leftover breezes in the
morning so here's your forecast
overnight 41 degrees
skies clearing winds stay light
and then we'll see those winds light
again tomorrow 60 degrees will be our
high
we'll also see sun and clouds in the
forecast again for tomorrow temperatures
will be above average
here are your neighborhoods now pick
them out here spring valley 59
along with desert shores summerlin 57 58
centennial hills
providence uh sky canyon there too 59
mountains edge
63 sunrise mountain green valley 62 58
for henderson 57 for pump
and laughlin at 68 degrees so we got to
cool down with those temp with those
winds too look at that back down in the
mid 50s by sunday
but look at next week then we get a
warming trend where we get to the high
60s mid to high 60s this time next week
that's way above average
we're not going to reach any records
just yet but we'll eye and see if that
forecast changes
with later updates as well that's your
most accurate weather we'll send it back
over to you